contrôler la conformité d'un permis de
conduire vérifier l'identité d'une
personne à travers les fichiers des
missions effectuées avec un smartphone
par les gendarmes
c'est le dispositif n'est aux gens de le
nouvel outil technologique distribuer à
la gendarmerie nationale des yvelines
pour contrôler le véhicule donc c'est
toujours dans la même application sauf
que du coup on va aller d'un véhicule et
donc on va cochet fauvet ce véhicule
donc pour voir si c'est pas un véhicule
volé et le système d'immatriculation et
voilà donc ensuite directement par le
lecteur de la bande
j'ai toutes les informations une
technologie utile dans la relation avec
les citoyens dans le cadre de
l'opération tranquillité vacances les
gendarmes géolocalise sur le smartphone
les maisons à surveiller vérification
des fenêtres des portails pour prévenir
des effractions
donc du coup une fois que tout ça c'est
terminé et qu'il n'y a rien à signaler
nous entrons dans l'application donc
notre passage
et ça envoie directement au propriétaire
du domicile 1-1 email lui disant qu'il
n'y a rien à signaler dans sa maison et
que nous sommes bien passé faciliter le
travail entre le terrain et la caserne
avec une évolution technologique d'un
ordinateur portable au début des années
2000 à une tablette numérique des
technologies collective on passe à un
outil individualisé à chaque gendarme
son smartphone il y à le mée manteau de
la police route donc qui intègre
l'ensemble des infractions qu'on est
susceptible de rencontrer à l'issue sa
part directement au centre de rennes qui
prend en compte la gestion finale des du
relevé d'infraction les infractions
répertoriés possèdent leurs références
aux textes législatifs ou réglementaires
avec les sanctions encourues
ce nouvel outil technologique s'inscrit
dans les réflexions en cours sur la
réforme de la police de sécurité du
quotidien voulue par le gouvernement